new possible issue along the lines of
it's not the crime it's the cover-up
potentially afflicting Donald Trump it
is now being explored
whether Trump provided doctored
Mar-A-Lago security footage now let me
back up and remind you what this is
about
we saw Trump's Mar-A-Lago home
um some call it rated a search warrant
was served people often get very upset
if you use one term or the other they
are often used interchangeably a search
warrant was indeed served at Mar-A-Lago
related to classified documents that
Donald Trump was asked to return and he
didn't and it's a major major
investigation that we've talked about
before one aspect of this is security
footage and there are now questions as
to whether
parts of the security footage were
removed or doctored by people working
for Donald Trump a couple articles about
this Esquire reports special counsel
Jack Smith has a few questions from
Mar-A-Lago security for example what
happened with the handling of
surveillance footage they subpoenaed a
Charlie Pierce
wrote this article and says lordy there
may be doctored tapes at least according
to CNL CNN Special counsel Jack Smith
has his special suspicions quoting the
handling of the footage and how
employees within the Trump organization
responded to the Justice Department's
demand for it have prompted a new round
of grand jury subpoenas to top Trump
employees in the last few weeks sources
told CNN longtime Trump organization
executive Matthew calamari and his son
Matthew calamari Jr are expected to
appear before the grand jury
investigating possible mishandling
prosecutors are expected to ask them
about the handling of the surveillance
footage and Trump employees
conversations following the subpoena
possible mishandling is prosecutor ease
for we've got these techies you see and
they're very good and they have some
questions the question here is about
whether the video surveillance footage
was indeed doctored Yahoo news uh sorry
CBS News via Yahoo life also writes
about this security camera video from
Mar-A-Lago Resort under scrutiny so
we've heard this term before this this
term it's not the crime it's the
cover-up that really could play a major
role here and in fact as we've talked
about before this has really been a
theme of much of the many of the
troubles that Donald Trump has had since
he became president
um even if we go back to the Mueller
probe the Russia probe As Trump calls it
Russia Russia Russia uh if from day one
Trump had merely said
uh I will cooperate with your
investigation we did nothing wrong I am
now president I'm focusing on running
the in uh the country and I will not be
making any public statements in order to
not Prejudice or influence or meddle
with this investigation ninety percent
of the Mueller probe would not have
taken place a lot of what ended up
happening was self-inflicted because
Donald Trump couldn't keep his mouth
shut and similarly
um you know you you've got the handling
of the documents themselves and that
would be adjudicated investigated
potentially adjudicated in the future
but if indeed the security footage
showing documents being moved around
shows uh that the documents were
deliberately hidden then you've got
layer one of the cover-up and then if
you've doctored the security footage of
you trying to hide the documents related
to the original inquiry we've now had
with we have a second layer of cover-up
which could play a major role so we will
watch it that's the latest suspicion
from the special counsel and we will see
what comes of that people often ask me
about my daily routine you know I'm
interviewed about the David packman show
how did you do it how do you do this and
like daily routine just often comes up
and how do you stay healthy and of
course I talk about exercise and I talk
about eating the right diet but one of
the things that can happen if you are
not eating the right diet or you're
traveling or life gets in the way is you
end up with some kind of vitamin
deficiency a daily scoop of ag1 from our
sponsor athletic greens makes this super
easy to take off of your list of things
to worry about one scoop of ag1 you get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals from Whole
Food sourced ingredients ag1 is cheaper
than dealing with a bunch of different
supplements it's infinitely more
convenient you just take a scoop before
you have your coffee for example as I do
in the morning and you're covered for
the entire day many of my friends love
ag1 anyone I mention it to seems to get
hooked when I go on vacation I bring the
ag1 travel packs with me especially
because I'm not always eating the same
diet when I'm traveling that I do at
home staying properly nourished so
important to feeling your best ag-1 just
makes it really easy and very convenient
go to athleticgreens.com Pacman to get a
free year supply of vitamin D I've
talked about vitamin D so many times
plus five free ag1 travel packs the link
is down below